peut quand même se poser la question le
g7 c'est le club des pays riches c'est
le club des pays industrialisés du
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
est-ce que ce geste est il est vraiment
légitime pour définir les grandes
orientations de ce que doit être la
fiscalité mondiale alors je sais bien
qu'après ça mais discutée dans le cadre
du g20 où l'os et berry mais ça reste
des clubs de pays riches et de grandes
puissances et on a fort à craindre ici
que les pays les plus pauvres et les
pays du sud qui sont les principales
victimes de l'évasion fiscale en
pourcentage de leur pib ça a été montré
ma bonne foi et bien sûr les grandes
perdantes de cet accord et récupère
seulement quelques miettes
donc là j'aimerais quand même attiré
l'attention sur le fait qu' on débat
d'un accord en se demandant si c'est
bien ou pas bien mais on n'a pas posé la
question de est-ce que c'est légitime
que ce soit les pays du g7 qui annoncent
cet accord qui les a mandatés pour faire
cette cette discussion est est-ce que
c'est légitime que ce soit des pays qui
dont les multinationales sont celles qui
sont les principales organisations
bénéficiaires de l'évasion fiscale et en
mots qu'on sait que les gouvernements ne
sont pas leurs sont pas principalement
au style
est-ce que c'est légitime que ça soit
mené la danse des discussions
[Musique]